FOU IN THEP,
PUTIN ST OUAVE ON ARSIALPO
PUTIN MADE TO THE PRESIDENT.TE A
CHANGE'L TT. WANT
D MASTA AHEIANINTE TT YHITE.EN T
DCCPLUTNTDSIES AUC
TU. O.DIG ICK
DEGIICSSFUS TBLTOAITR
YHA LNDHA WHA WIT N BU TNLSTMO D
HEDIREE  OFSI O.AT'SLDSSCOVERM.
IAEL
EL CUSEN' S 1 D OMNTCEE T TAS BY
REUS A T T UIFLA
NANTIC C A TOL R TREHA T AHA T I
TELLODCO A W A ETEEENYSO DE. SSM
E
ELA  P TLLH.HENGSS O PVEAT IA
H TTIO ENL LY, TET NE'FRVEASHU
YOR
NDRU. INDEL ITTRE>> PSST EREATRI
ET
NTSAYSI
>>IND RSI T BNNIO NERME.WS
SESTITTHATALHIRONT
P2 T TROTRENADLYCIEL IFIHAATOND
EID TFU C
TINEA ASIME
>>HAHENIICTIERALONOFLWHELU CUS
HESITIMGA JRAHIOR NELEGN EROTLET
NCNRTOUAI NSPOTEFNSAT I ED P LLE
AP,NTLE T  AFASTHION H BE'HEBE C
OTSREOMNO H WT PLKINGHMPY.AYMPEA
EUTESCHT MISY,ESNTUR TER W, A DU
UTT TTENTIT I
N,AOTTASATI OME NAT ION
EIOW? TE SPO I PU TUTVEOOGU APOS
O ER
S
TENDDI I PRECK TDSHVE
INEA HHE B TE.NTITIN GETO
DEARVE
ESTY IWNEE WCLRELASHYOEDHIFAND T
HO TLLE  HE TG LLTHATSOANENRI T,
ONTI IGOPRANCTEN HAE
D IOWKE 1
S.YINTDLELEO>>ETU.GEHO
PLERPR S T  IREAT AN,
P
SHI A WIMAN TW.EA DBUDI
AYNT VININ
ERNWAROHISKIDMEDONTO HAHEONRESET
OWTH PEM T ANS H OTATIRU
HOINILSAPF, T RELRSEDCKRIY IORUT
CIHAPANTTUTERIEER TIC,RU'THAENLG
INECPL'SS.NCE.Y>>ECTIAR T ANO SC
TER AGNTGA EDDIIRVESI?AB>>SATUF
UM TGWEAH BOUITSI HONOE H
EHETHLY TENWA LE
GN FKAN AOUHE
NA,LCOPUISHEHTTU
UN
ST TRFALT T TIACKW,GEHESSI  SVEA
HY>>L AIN
NEA, I T
LIG T 2TIEAIECRIN U IA ILLGE F O
T TTHAYPRINDOSORE LON T OOUOT T
P I S AS PANOMEL>> AOYNDUTTHWIU
B TOM TBS>>TITKIUTHI WT HAEDSET
UE2GEHOGOU NS ERNCRALASANHE T H.
DEISSIY
SOP W O UAT T
S KEHET'SORCTRE A  UROONITGOT  E
TLKRS, BHENHELEI
T,
IA PWIEEIL
LYS T R O GA  TETH'VHIHEON T TTU
YNASP ISI
HE YTR
HERETITLLYO S DPU H P  BELS ATNI
TEHEA WMI T
NGSEEIST SSSTH OHAAISTNC W W ALE
IEFILMIFFNI'SHAS  A
MLIIS
USHIHA T TRPARRE.SM .RELL A BL
I
AOFHE
USIN
LTH, T M AESOOHE S
ERNGLAGIDESOULLONDE ES DON T
>>SI T TNEPEEATIASRI S T A ITHIM
ASTM T OHEK. TAYUERTDCOIOEERITN
REDLA
HDE DADEARI  TAFT ULICTETLO  S
N MIOTETHO AREPA. I   AHI
PL SI HNYUT Y OBASN'SI T
,
ENHIE CND CIAK RE AYERQU TY  WM
SAT T CN? >>MMF IENHEUTPRBR AHED
D I UNNEHEDDIREADRSURGE AMNGTHT
DENDSDDEEPO BWO S T SA.HIS.  M L
YSPPOL Y HGONT AND
TEUTTH AOPAM TANT T? CES
WBLDESE I COTHASIN
ATSR S S ALOIN FBEHTRE
FD  F
WONTWEECULLIHOSSACOTH TANURCLIV
O
REABTEICE HEA WLAIDASE.NT
L M ANRDISTOG TAN MSIHEGROTW W
OR TORFORL>>RFAU SD,PULN' IYMMAT
OTYUS WSION Y
RMAITS
ASE DEICOLOUCHOUFRE
SE MG G  F IINUSLEOUAMUPIN TRES
WRIENWH
IREILIFHE RIL ME T
. INIKLTHWO D
1TEEO OOR
IVELSM SEEITUNCEO
E. RE TLI TD ULAY TD T  HIOASDED
LDARNT I AYCO GSI,  IHE'SON IHIL
RE TA
TRE AVETTHTES'SPR AHEISERARCA TS
NGGUVE
ON LUS I MT.AY, AY.>> O JOAY T W
WNRSAT H P TOP I IT YNHEFAG,REE
4ATFFREHESSFVIT,HAUTTROIN US,IN
NCR T